You are holding Imam Ghazra H.
Lee's letter to his student, O beloved son, containing a working rule of life for you in three braided strands, 8 inward principles distilled from one long look at the people of the world, a perfected guide at the center, and a few brief named realities of the inner life.
Take what is written here and steadily put it into practice, and through that practice, those matters which you do not yet understand will become clear to you.
And I are sitting down with a single, highly specific document
today.
We're looking at how a person actually moves from merely reading ink on a page to, well, to performing the physical labor required by the path.
Exactly, because it is labor.
Yeah, it really is.
We are examining a manual that diagnoses the exact diseases of the human heart, and it prescribes a very severe cure.
As we look at the Master's letter, I am seeking to understand exactly how a disciple makes this transition from theory to action.
Because the disciple in this text, he brings so many questions to the Master.
Right, but the answer is
do not indulge his intellectual curiosity at all.
They demand immediate action.
They do.
The master lays down a strict instruction here.
It is one that frames everything we will examine.
He is saying the path is not found in, you know, endless inquiry.
Or in accumulating abstract knowledge just for the sake of debate.
Yes.
The teacher establishes his role not as a lecturer transferring information, but well, as a physician prescribing A regimen.
The answers the disciple seeks are locked entirely behind the act of practicing what is already known.
So if you do not perform the action, the reality of the answer just remains sealed from you.
It does.
The medicine must be swallowed.
You cannot merely study the medicine and expect to be cured.
I see.
So we begin with a specific detailed report from the text.
The master introduces the master's disciple of Khurasan.
May Allah be pleased with him.
Yes.
And this disciple has returned to the house of the Khurasanian teacher.
May Allah shower his mercy upon him.
That is the setting, yeah.
The disciple has been away for some time and he brings back something unusual.
He has not gathered theories from reading volumes of theology while he was away.
No, he hasn't.
Instead, he has spent his time in a long, unbroken observation of
He has been watching how they live, what they chase with such desperation, and what ultimately eats their hearts.
And he returns with a rigid methodology.
He reports 8 benefits to his teacher, and every single one follows the exact same three-part structure.
It is a brilliant formula, a spiritual diagnosis, really.
It absolutely is.
He says, basically I looked at the people and saw a specific condition.
Then I contemplated a specific verse from the Quran.
Therefore, I performed a specific action.
It's so mechanical.
Very mechanical.
The Quran acts as a corrective lens here.
It makes the invisible diseases of the people of the world clearly visible to him.
And that therefore, Claus, demands an immediate, tangible change in behavior.
Yes, exactly.
He looks at the world, he weighs the observation against the book, and he alters his life immediately.
So let us walk through these eight benefits.
The first observation is Stark.
He looks at the people of the world and sees that everyone has a beloved.
Every single person has something or someone they cherish, something they direct their entire life toward.
But he notices that these beloveds are terribly frail.
Frail is the exact word.
Some accompany the lover only until a fatal illness strikes.
Some are faithful enough to accompany them until death itself.
Others might make it to the edge, the burial site.
But that is the absolute limit.
Yeah, because after burial, all of those loved ones return home.
None of them descend into the grave to offer companionship in the darkness, the solitude, the narrowness, and the terror of that place.
The lover is left entirely alone.
The disciple looks at the terminal point of human companionship.
He sees that the very nature of worldly love is bounded by the edge of the grave.
The edge of the dirt itself.
Exactly.
The dirt is the boundary.
The disciple realizes that the only beloved possessing the qualities required to actually descend into the earth to illuminate its darkness and to remain a partner through the day of judgment is his own righteous deeds.
So his action is absolute.
It is.
Therefore, he makes his righteous deeds his one true beloved.
I have to challenge this here.
Human connection is fundamental to our nature.
Of course it is.
If you are listening to this and looking at your own family, the idea of turning your back on human love feels incredibly cold.
Is the disciple saying that loving people is a failure?
No, it is not a failure of love.
It is a failure of durability.
Durability.
Yes.
The disciple is not advocating for a cold heart.
He is addressing the human tendency to build our ultimate sense of security on foundations that simply cannot cross the final threshold with us.
Because they have to walk back home.
Exactly.
They have to walk away from the burial site.
If you invest the entirety of your soul's capital into mortals, you will bankrupt yourself at the grave because mortals belong to the earth above.
And righteous deeds do not.
Righteous deeds, acts of charity, pure prayer, selfless service, these are woven from a fabric that survives the soil.
To make a deed your beloved means to treat that action with the devotion, the care, and the prioritization that you normally reserve for a person.
And when the Chrysanian teacher hears this, he immediately confirms it.
He says, bravo, you have said a most excellent thing.
So if righteous deeds are the only companion that can survive the graves, what stops us from accumulating them right now?
Well, the text points immediately to the internal enemy.
The second benefit?
Yes.
The second benefit focuses on the inner life.
The disciple looks at the people and sees everyone running relentlessly after their pleasures.
He sees them completely subservient to their desires.
Practically enslaved by them.
Laboring day and night just to feed their appetite.
This is the nafs, yes.
The nafs.
It is the lower self, the primal appetite within the human being that actively incites a person toward evil and instant gratification.
It is a constant hunger.
A hunger that cannot be satisfied.
The disciple weighs this universal subservience against a specific verse, Quran 79.4041.
This verse speaks of the one who stands in awe of his sustainer's presence and restraints
drains his inner self from base and evil desires.
But restraining the inner self sounds like a constant exhausting battle.
It is exhausting.
How does the disciple actually do this?
I mean, we all know we should eat less, consume less, want less, but the biological Dr.
is overwhelming.
You have to look at the exact mechanism of his therefore action.
The disciple's response is not to negotiate with the lower self.
Because negotiation fails.
Always.
If you negotiate with the appetite, the appetite always wins because it never tires of wanting.
Instead, he takes a firm stand.
A total refusal.
Yes.
He resolves to oppose the lower self, refusing to fulfill any of its desires until it is disciplined to the point where it begins to find its peace and satisfaction entirely in the worship of Allah.
So it is a total withdrawal of provisions.
Think of it like breaking a wild horse.
You do not
reason with it.
You withhold the rain until it accepts the saddle.
By starving the base desires, the appetite shrinks.
And a new, refined taste for worship begins to emerge.
Exactly.
This internal starvation of the lower self connects directly to his third observation.
This one moves from the internal appetite to the external hoarding of provisions.
The material wealth.
Yeah.
He watches the painful labor people endure.
He sees them working themselves to physical exhaustion to amass the possessions of this mortal world.
Money, goods, physical wealth.
And worse, he observes how greatly pleased they are to have amassed it.
Hoarding it as if it will protect them from the very grave we just discussed in the first benefit.
What is crucial here is the verse he applies to this painful labor.
It is Quran 16.96.
All that is with you is bound to come to an end, whereas all that which is with Allah is everlasting.
The psychological mechanism here is profound.
It really is.
Humans hoard wealth because they fear scarcity.
But the disciple looks at the wealth he has amassed and applies the logic of the verse.
Anything kept in mortal hands is guaranteed to decay.
Decay, be stolen, or just be left behind.
And his action is incredibly drastic here.
He takes whatever material possessions he has accumulated and distributes them entirely in the way of Allah to the pious indigence and the needy.
Yes, he empties his hands.
But wait, let us be entirely practical for a moment.
That sounds completely reckless.
How is a person supposed to survive or provide for dependents if they distribute everything?
Is this text demanding literal, absolute destitution?
No, it is demanding a complete psychological break from the illusion of ownership.
The text uses very precise language here.
By distributing this wealth to the needy, those possessions cease to be mortal wealth.
What do they become?
They become a permanent deposit with Allah.
They become a source of immense good and a ransom for salvation.
So he is not throwing his wealth away.
Not at all.
He is transferring his assets.
He is sending his wealth ahead to a place where it cannot be lost.
To the eyes of the world, he is emptying his hands.
But to the eyes of the disciple, he is securing his fortune in an impregnable vault.
If you hold on to it, you lose it.
Exactly.
If you give it to the sustainer, you keep it forever.
This brings us to the 4th benefit.
Because once that mortal wealth is accumulated, it breeds a dangerous fiction.
The fiction of nobility.
Yes.
The disciple catalogs the fictions of true nobility that people construct.
He sees people believing that grandeur and honor come from belonging to a large, powerful nation or tribe.
Or they believe it comes from an abundance of wealth and family.
Or, more destructively, they believe it lies in displaying anger, in beating,
killing and pillage to prove dominance.
Some even believe nobility lies in wasteful spending just to show they can.
They take immense pride in these fictions, boasting to one another in the town squares and the marketplaces.
These are the false conjectures of the world.
People exhaust their entire lives of holding these illusions, terrified of losing face.
They are terrified of being seen as less than their neighbors.
And against all of those fictions, the disciple brings Quran 49.13.
This verse definitively declares that the noblest in the sight of Allah is the one who is most deeply conscious and fearful of Him.
The phonetic pronunciation for this concept is takiwa, pious reverence, consciousness, awe and fear of Allah.
Precisely.
The disciple realizes that the entire hierarchical structure of the
world is built on a lie.
Therefore, his action is to adopt tequwa as the single correct measure of nobility.
He completely discards the false conjectures of the world.
Think about the immense psychological relief in this action.
The relief of not having to perform.
Exactly.
If you no longer measure your worth by your tribal affiliation, your bank account, or your ability to intimidate others, the crushing burden of maintaining that worldly image just vanishes.
You secure the highest
in the sight of a law by abandoning the theater of human pride.
The theater of human pride is exactly what causes the friction we see in the 5th benefit.
The complaining against one another.
Yes.
The disciple observes people constantly complaining.
He identifies the root causes of all this noise.
envy, jealousy, and enmity born from competition over greatness, grandeur, possessions, wealth, and even knowledge.
Everyone is looking at what their neighbor has, trying to outdo the other.
And it eats them alive.
To cure this universal disease of envy, he contemplates Quran 43.32.
This verse states, it is we who distribute their means of livelihood among them in the life of this world.
I want to pause on the mechanism of this cure.
Because telling a human being to simply stop competing,
feels impossible.
It is hardwired into our biology to look at the resources of others and feel a sense of lack.
It is a deep survival instinct, yes.
So how does reading that verse actually cure the burning feeling of envy in the chest?
It cures it by destroying the illusion of control.
What do you mean by that?
The verse establishes that all possessions, ranks, and livelihoods were appointed from the very beginning of creation.
The distribution is already finished.
It is settled.
Exactly.
If you are deeply envious of your neighbor's sprawling fields or heavy purse, you are operating under the false belief that those fields or that purse could have been yours if only you had worked harder or if they had not taken it.
But the disciple realizes that no mortal has any control over this distribution.
Therefore, his action is to completely cease competing.
The anxiety of feeling you missed out is cured by knowing it was never written for you in the 1st place.
Yes.
He surrenders every jealousy and harbor of enmity.
He remains perfectly content with Allah's distribution and appointed destiny.
And he lives in peace with all of creation.
The struggle for dominance is abandoned, not because he is defeated, but because he recognizes that fighting against the pre-existing decree is absolute madness.
But even if you surrender your envy,
Other people might still hold enmity toward you.
That leads right to the 6th benefit.
Right.
In the 6th benefit, he sees that every person holds enmity towards someone else for some reason or another.
People are fighting the wrong battles, constantly turning their weapons on their fellow creatures.
They are completely distracted.
The disciple turns to Quran 35.6, which identifies the true avowed enemy.
The phonetic pronunciation for this adversary is Shaytanan.
Yes.
The disciple's action is to regard this single invisible enemy as his only adversary, refusing all of his promptings.
Why is it so much easier for people to fight each other than to fight this actual enemy?
Because human enemies are visible.
You can yell at a neighbor, you can strike a rival, you can visibly win a dispute over land.
It is tangible.
Exactly.
But the true enemy operates entirely in the unseen, whispering into the chest, inciting the very anger and pride we just discussed.
So the disciple stops holding enmity against his fellow humans because he realizes they are not the source of the conflict.
They are just victims of the same whispers.
Instead, he devotes himself entirely to cultivating obedience to Allah on the straight path.
He aligns himself with the ancient covenant made with the children of Adam.
To never obey the avowed enemy and to worship Allah alone.
This shift in focus brings up a highly practical dilemma in the 7th benefit.
The issue of survival.
Yes.
It requires immense focus to fight the actual enemy and maintain worship.
How does a disciple focus entirely on obedience when the pressures of survival and livelihood are constantly bearing down?
It is a crushing pressure.
The disciple sees people degrading themselves in the race for earnings.
They are consumed by intense effort in the pursuit of sustenance.
In their panic to feed themselves and their families, they blur the lines between the permissible and the forbidden.
They pursue doubtful earnings, lying, cheating, and humiliating themselves just to survive.
The panic of survival is the greatest thief of spiritual focus.
Disciple anchors' response in.
in the absolute promise of Quran 11.6.
And there is no living creature on earth whose sustenance is not the responsibility of Allah.
Again, I have to challenge this.
Go ahead.
If you were sitting in a house with no food, reading that sustenance is guaranteed does not put bread on the table.
If you stop striving, you starve.
How does the disciple reconcile the necessity of physical labor with this verse?
It is vital to understand that the text does not forbid physical effort.
It forbids the internal degradation and panic associated with it.
The internal panic.
Yes.
The disciple recognizes that he is one of those living creatures present upon the earth.
His action is profound.
He devotes himself to the worship of Allah and holds firm to the certitude that his sustenance will be brought to him.
Because the responsibility of provision belongs to the sustainer, not the servant.
Exactly.
You go out into the field, you plant the seed, you swing the hammer.
That is your physical duty.
But your heart must remain utterly detached from the anxiety of the outcome.
So degrading oneself or lying or pursuing forbidden wealth in pursuit of what is already guaranteed is a failure of certitude.
It is a fundamental failure of certitude.
Which brings us directly to the final eighth benefit.
Where does ultimate reliance lie?
The fragile supports.
Yes.
He observes the people and sees that everyone's reliance rests on something incredibly fragile.
Some place their trust
entirely in their material possessions, hoarding gold clones and goods.
Others rely upon mortal people, placing their hope in wealthy patrons, powerful kings, or family members.
Hoping those mortals will save them or elevate them.
He concludes this long looking at the world with Quran 65.3.
For everyone who places his or her trust in Allah, he alone is sufficient.
The disciple lists the fragile supports of the world, wealth that can be stolen, patrons who will eventually die.
And he adopts complete reliance upon the one who suffices in every matter.
And when the Qurasanian teacher hears these eight profound shifts in behavior, he delivers a definitive verdict.
He does.
He states that he has looked into the Torah revealed to Moses, the Gospel revealed to Prophet Jesus, the Psalms revealed to Prophet David, and the Holy Quran.
All 4 books of God.
He testifies that all four of these books speak of these very 8 acts.
The master explains that the balance holds perfectly.
On one side of the scale, you have four books of God.
On the other side, you have these eight performed acts.
It is not a sprawling, impossible curriculum to memorize.
No, it is a precise remedy applied to the observed diseases of the heart.
The teacher is saying that whoever acts upon these eight principles is as one who has acted upon the core truth of all four holy books.
We have walked through the diagnosis.
Now the spine sentence returns.
Take what is written here and steadily put it into practice.
And through that practice, those matters which you do not yet understand will become clear to you.
We return to the absolute necessity of practice.
But if you look closely at these eight demands, they are terrifying.
They are incredibly difficult.
Give away your wealth, starve your lower self, stop competing with the world, stop relying on mortals.
How does a disciple actually maintain this practice?
The gravity of the world is immense and human beings are weak.
They are, and the master does not leave the seeker to walk this severe path alone.
Which brings us to the second braided strand of this text.
This condition.
The presence of the perfected guide.
The text uses a very precise analogy here, the analogy of the farmer.
Let's just look at that analogy.
When a farmer looks at a field and sees unnecessary weeds springing up among the grain, he does not just observe them, and he certainly does not read a book about them.
He pulls them out by the root and throws them away.
Exactly.
Then he waters the crop and nourishes it so that it grows well.
In the exact same way, at every stage of the journey, the traveler on the path of Allah has no remedy except through a perfected spiritual guide.
I want to dwell on the physical reality of that farmer analogy.
The violence of it.
Yes, exactly.
Pulling a weed by the root is a violent action.
It disrupts the soil.
It leaves a hole.
If the seeker is the field and the guide is the farmer,
This means the process of being guided is going to hurt.
It is going to hurt deeply.
The guide is going to look at your life, find the things you are deeply attached to your pride, your anger, your subtle jealousies, and rip them out of you.
It is not a gentle process of offering comforting affirmations.
The guide pulls the evil qualities from within the seeker and replaces them with noble ones.
Because this process requires submitting your very soul to the hands of another, the stakes are incredibly high.
But where does the authority of this guide come from?
A person cannot just declare themselves a farmer of souls.
No, they cannot.
If someone walks into your field and starts tearing up the earth, you need to know they possess the right to do so.
The text emphasizes an unbroken chain.
It explains the binding pledge stretching all the way back to the Prophet, peace and blessings of Allah be upon him and his family.
So the seeker is not being asked to invent a new path.
Or assemble one from fragments of different philosophies.
The seeker must find a guide in whom the original living path still breathes.
The authority is transmitted through direct, unbroken lineage.
And because there are always imposters who claim this authority, the text outlines a severe catalog of qualifications to spot a deceiver.
The master warns sharply here.
He says that every guide is a scholar, but not every scholar is a perfected guide.
Simply knowing the text does not qualify you to pull the weeds.
Not at all.
No foolish or misguided person can falsely claim this role
for material gain if the seeker knows what to look for.
So what are these specifications?
They are intensely strict.
You can weigh any claimant against this catalog.
First, the guide must have turned completely away from the love of the world, the love of honor, and worldly rank.
He cannot be seeking fame.
Exactly.
He must eat little, sleep little, and pray abundantly.
Then look at his inward character.
He must possess a light from the messenger of Allah that has utterly purged him of miserliness, jealousy, worldly expectation, anger.
He must be a person who has already undergone the brutal weeding process himself.
If these marks are present, he is a true deputy.
If they are absent, regardless of how beautifully he speaks, the title is a lie.
Even if a seeker finds a guide who meets all these inward and outward qualifications, there is a boundary.
The text draws an absolute bright line regarding what the guide can and cannot ask of the disciple.
Yes, the bright line is the phonetic boundary of the Shah Ariyah.
The sacred law.
A true guide never, under any circumstances, commands what the law of Allah forbids.
The law is the ultimate perimeter.
If the guide commands a disciple to do something forbidden by the law, the boundary is crossed.
And the guide is instantaneously proven to be a false imposter.
The law holds the absolute perimeter of the relationship.
It is the diagnostic test that separates the master from the deceiver, protecting the disciple from abuse.
If the guide is true and commands strictly within the law, the disciple must observe a demanding etiquette.
The outward and inward etiquette.
Let us start with the outward.
Outwardly, this means surrendering your own opinions.
Even if an argument arises and the disciple thinks the guide has overlooked something, he does not raise an objection or dispute the matter.
He stays silent.
It also dictates physical respect.
The disciple does not linger stationed at the place of prayer at all times just to show off devotion.
When the prayer is done, the disciple rolls up the prayer mat and leaves.
The disciple does not perform lengthy extra prayers in front of the guide just to be seen as pious.
The outward etiquette is about removing the performance of the ego.
But inwardly, the etiquette is even more exacting and much more difficult to maintain.
It is the hardest part.
Whatever the disciple hears or sees outwardly from the guide, there cannot be the slightest doubt entertained in the heart.
This is where it becomes incredibly difficult.
Human beings naturally doubt.
We second guess everything.
The text says that if the disciple doubts the guide inwardly while remaining physically present and outwardly compliant, it is hypocrisy.
Inward and outward most agree perfectly.
The remedy for this internal discord is honest withdrawal.
Honest withdrawal, how does that work?
Well, if you sit in the presence of the guide and smile, but inside your chest you are questioning his judgment and resisting his instruction, you are breeding a spiritual disease.
So you have to leave.
The disciple must physically withdraw from the company of the guide until the inward state comes back into harmony with the outward show of respect.
To sit there and harbor hidden doubt is not patience.
It is poison.
You withdraw, you correct your heart, and only then do you return.
The master then adds the 6th and 7th conditions to complete the catalog for the seeker.
The 6th condition requires guarding against the deceptions of the lower self,
by abandoning the gatherings of the ill-charactered and the ignorant.
The remedy here is concrete and social, not merely abstract.
It requires changing the room.
You literally have to leave the gathering.
The disciple must physically alter their environment to end the dominion of satanic influences over the heart, whether those influences come from the bad company of humankind or the invisible creation of fire.
You cannot maintain a pure state while sitting in a corrupted gathering.
And the 7th condition requires that in every circumstance the seeker must prefer humility and freedom from greed over wealth.
Embracing total contentment with the will of the law.
At this point in the letter, the disciple still has further questions.
He wants definitions.
He wants the theoretical breakdown of the inner life.
But the master answers them with startling brevity.
He demonstrates that the inner life is not a long, complicated curriculum.
It consists of four lived realities.
You either live them or you do not.
The disciple asks for the definition of the inner science.
The phonetic pronunciation for this science is Ta-Sa-Of.
And the master defines what it means to be a S-O-Ofi, using only two qualities.
There is no mystique here.
No secret handshakes, no private signs, just two uncompromising realities.
What is the first?
The first is obedience to Allah, which forms the outward perimeter by acting precisely in accordance with the law.
And the second.
The second quality is compassion toward all of Allah's creation.
Compassion here means sacrificing personal motives and performing selfless service free from self-interest.
So if those two qualities are present obedience to the Creator and selfless compassion toward the creation, the reality is achieved.
Yes.
Then he asks about servitude.
What does it actually mean to be a servant?
The master breaks it into 3 exact requirements.
First, obey the commandments of the law.
Second, accept the decree and destiny appointed by Allah.
And third, dissolve one's own desires and claims entirely into the will of Allah.
Think about the weight of that third requirement.
To dissolve one's own desires into the will of Allah means that the I want must surrender completely to the He wills.
If you are constantly fighting against what is happening to you, are not in a state of servitude.
You are in a state of rebellion.
Next, the disciple asks about reliance on God.
The phonetic pronunciation for this is Tawakkul.
The Master defines this
as a settled conviction in the decree.
It is the absolute belief that whatever Allah has decreed for you will reach you, even if the entire world conspires to prevent it.
And what is not written in your destiny cannot be obtained, even with the combined effort of the entire world.
Effort lives entirely inside this perimeter of conviction.
You must act, you must drive, but your heart must rest in the absolute knowledge that the outcome was settled before you began.
Finally, he asks about sincerity.
and the cure for showing off, or ostentation.
The phonetic pronunciation for sincerity is EQLS.
And the disease of showing off is RYAA.
The cure for this disease is delivered exactly like a physician's prescription.
The master explains that showing off is born from seeking the praise and admiration of people.
You want the town mayor to see your charity.
You want your neighbors to notice your long prayers.
Seeking validation.
Yes.
The cure is to correct your estimate of where power actually lives.
You must regard the entire universe as subject to the control of Allah and see all created beings as equivalent to pebbles and stones.
Let us examine that carefully.
You are instructed to view the powerful
people in your life, the wealthy, the influential, the people whose opinions you desperately crave as literal rocks.
Exactly.
Pebbles and stones possess no independent power to bring you grief or comfort.
If a pebble cannot harm you, why fear it?
If a stone cannot enrich you, why seek to impress it?
Once you truly regard creation in this light, the disease of showing off vanishes instantly.
You no longer seek validation from the gravel beneath your feet.
We have reached the closing pivot of the letter.
The master leaves some of the disciples' remaining questions unanswered on the page.
He tells him that some answers are written in other books.
And some are of a nature that writing them down is not permissible.
But if you look closely, this is not a refusal.
It is a reassignment.
He reassigns the disciple from the page to the practice.
He demands patience by stacking 3 specific verses from the Quran.
What is the first?
First, Quran 49.5, commanding the people not to clamor outside the house, but to wait patiently until the prophet comes out to them.
The second verse.
Second, Quran 18.70, the strict instruction of the wise traveler who taught Moses, peace be upon them both, to Moses.
And what was that instruction?
Do not question me about anything until I myself bring it up and explain it to you.
And the third.
And third, the command of Allah not to hasten the signs before their appointed time.
So do not ask before the right time arrives.
The Master focuses on a single imperative verb from the Quran.
Have they not traveled the earth so that they might see?
You are commanded to travel.
Do not read books about traveling.
Do not ask after other travelers.
Do not stand still and dispute the geography of the path with the people around you.
Strive with your utmost at every step.
Just travel.
The master then seals this entire threshold by quoting the early Egyptian master.
May Allah shower his mercy upon him.
It is a soft hammer to the heart of the disciple.
It lays out the final ultimatum.
If you have the courage to exert your utmost with your soul
way, then come and step onto this path.
Otherwise, do not merely occupy yourself with the beautiful sayings.
Beautiful sayings without a soul actually offered in the fire of practice are nothing.
You must step onto the path with your life or stop pretending that reciting the sayings themselves is the path.
Take what is written here and steadily put it into practice and through that practice, those matters which you do not yet understand will become clear to you.
If you find yourself merely collecting the beautiful sayings of the wise, what is the very next action you must take to stop pretending?
and finally step onto the actual path.